-Hmm hmm, action! (voix off)
-Ah, ça tourne?
-Ben, on va essayer de faire un nouvel épisode!
T'as rechangé de tenue?
-C'est plus l'été. Tu sais quel jour on
est d'ailleurs?
-...
-On est le 13 octobre.
-Oui... Alors, de quoi on parle?
-Il se passe quelque chose le 13 octobre!
-Euuuh... Mais oui, tu es un génie!
Bonjour, nous sommes le 13 octobre, et il
y a exactement 708 ans étaient arrêtés
tous les templiers de France. A cette occasion
nous reviendrons sur leur création, leur
parcours, et leur destruction.
-En fait... C'était l'anniversaire de ta
mère. Je savais pas, pour les templiers.
-OK. Mais on va quand même faire un épisode
sur eux!
Je précise tout de suite que nous nous intéresserons
ici aux faits historiques, et non aux très
nombreuses légendes qui circulent sur les
templiers. Si vous vous intéressez aux complots
sur le trésor des templiers Nicolas Cage
vous renseignera mieux que moi, si vous êtes
un fan des rois maudits nous verrons que cette
histoire repose sur du n'importe quoi et si
vous êtes bloqué dans Assassin's Creed I
sautez dans une botte de paille et laissez-moi
vous raconter la véritable histoire des templiers
telle que vous ne l'avez jamais entendue.
Tout commence avec les Croisades, même si
à l'époque on parle plutôt de pèlerinage,
le terme de croisade apparaissant pour la
première fois au XVe siècle.
A la fin du XIe siècle, la terre sainte est
une destination très prisée pour les chrétiens
d'occident qui rêvent de passer leurs vacances
à se prélasser dans les lieux saints de
Jérusalem.
Malheureusement pour eux, l'endroit est très
mal fréquenté depuis quelques temps puisqu'il
a été conquis par les turcs seljoukides.
qui s'en donnent à cœur joie pour raquetter
voire assassiner les pauvres chrétiens qui
voulaient juste voir du pays.
Le but de la première croisade est donc de
redonner l'accès aux lieux saints aux pèlerins,
et si possible de conquérir ces terres tout
simplement. Jérusalem est donc reprise en
1099, ce qui permet la création des États
latins d'Orient.
-Et les templiers dans tout ça?
J'y arrive. Après la prise de Jérusalem,
plusieurs ordres religieux se mettent en place.
Les chanoines du Saint Sépulcre, tout d'abord,
s'occupent des affaires religieuses dans le
Saint Sépulcre auquel les chrétiens ont
de nouveau accès. En 1113 est aussi crée
l'ordre de l'hôpital qui protège ces chanoines
et s'occupe de la charité. Les hospitaliers
sont un peu débordés, et Hugues de Payns,
qui arrive en terre sainte quelques années
après la première croisade, a l'idée de
créer un nouvel ordre qui s'occuperait uniquement
de la protection des chanoines et des pèlerins
en route pour Jérusalem.
En 1120 est donc reconnu par l'Eglise la milice
des pauvres chevaliers du Christ et du temple
de Salomon, un ordre à la fois religieux
et militaire.
Je croyais qu'on allait parler des templiers.
Ce sont les templiers. Le roi de Jérusalem
Baudoin II leur permet de s'installer dans
une partie de son palais, qui correspondrait
à l'emplacement du temple de Salomon selon
l'Ancien Testament.
Aaaaah mais c'est pour ça qu'on les appelle
templiers!
Oui. Bon, au début ils ont un petit budget,
peu de personnel, donc ils se contentent de
surveiller UN défilé, le défilé d'Athlit,
dans lequel les pèlerins étaient souvent
pris en embuscade par des bandits.
Ensuite, Hugues de Payns et son compagnon
Godefroy de Saint-Omer décident de rentrer
en Occident pour une grande tournée visant
à faire la promotion de leur ordre.
Bonjour, pourrions-nous vous parler de notre
ordre religieux?
Ils parviennent à se faire reconnaître par
le pape himself ce qui leur permet de devenir
l'ordre religieux à rejoindre.
Vous aimez vous battre. Mais vous songez aussi
à une carrière religieuse? N'hésitez-plus!
Avec les templiers, vous pourrez combiner
vos deux passions!
Mais comment fonctionne cet ordre, et comment
devenir templier?
Prenons l'exemple de cette jeune fille.
Pardon, ce jeune homme.
Il devra prononcer trois vœux: pauvreté,
chasteté et obéissance.
-attends, c'était quoi le deuxième vœu?!
Il peut être aussi bien noble ou simple pécore,il
doit avoir plus de 18 ans, ne pas être fiancé,
ne pas faire partie d'un autre ordre, ne pas
être excommunié ni endetté, ne pas être
serf, s'engager pour la vie et être en parfaite
santé physique ou mentale.
Ça va, j'peux rester?
On va dire que ça passe. Tu as aussi l'interdiction
de mentir.
En dehors du fait que j'suis une femme que
tu viens de déguiser en homme, tout baigne.
Comme dans tout ordre monastique, les templiers
étaient soumis à une hiérarchie avec à
leur tête les maîtres, qui dirigeaient l'ensemble
des commanderies de leur pays. A leur tête
se trouvait un maître général désigné
à vie. Les templiers obtiennent leur propre
drapeau en 1147, et n'en déplaise à Ridley
Scott il est stipulé dans leurs règles qu'ils
ont les cheveux coupés ras.
Ah non. La chasteté ok, mais pas les cheveux!
Les templiers s'avèrent des combattants redoutables
face aux arabes, et en 1129 ils intègrent
l'armée du roi. Ils ne se contentent donc
pas de protéger les pèlerins mais prennent
part aux grandes batailles entre les francs
et les arabes comme la bataille de Hattin,
qui est montrée dans le film Kingdom of Heaven
et qui se termine en grooosse défaite pour
les francs.
Tous les templiers présents sont faits prisonniers
par les armées de Saladin (Salah al-dîn
pour les intimes) et ils sont tous exécutés.
Et tu voulais montrer qu'ils étaient de bons
combattants, c'est ça?
En d'autres occasions, ils ont été forts.
Comme source de financement, les templiers
reçoivent des dons, dans un premier temps,
et s'enrichissent en accordant des prêts
à des personnes allant de simples croisés
aux rois d'Europe. Sans devenir la banque
templière, cette petite activité leur permet
de vivre confortablement.
Le roi Louis VII a tellement confiance en
eux qu'il confie aux templiers de Paris la
garde de son trésor royal pendant qu'il part
en croisade. Il est imité par ses successeurs,
et par le roi Henri II d'Angleterre.
On a beaucoup parlé de la fortune des templiers
mais la plus grande partie de leur patrimoine
venait de biens fonciers, des monastères
en Occident et des forteresses en Orient.
Point donc de merveilleux trésor caché ni
de graal défendu par les templiers.
De toute façon, le graal, c'est...
Un bocal à anchois?
Non, c'est une invention arthurienne. T'es
bizarre.
Malheureusement, la perte de Saint Jean d'Acre
en 1291 oblige les chrétiens à quitter la
terre sainte. C'est la fin d'une époque pour
les templiers, dont le siège est transféré
à Chypre mais en l'absence de pèlerins à
protéger, on commence à s'interroger sur
leur utilité.
Plusieurs facteurs expliquent leur chute:
leur inutilité, depuis la perte de la terre
sainte, mais aussi la richesse dans laquelle
certains vivaient et qui éveillait les jalousies.
De plus le roi de France Philippe IV le Bel
est en conflit avec le pape et craint un petit
peu cette armée de 15 000 hommes entièrement
dévouée à ce dernier.
Il profite donc des confessions d'un ancien
templier qui prétend que ses confrères se
livrent à toutes sortes de pratiques peu
communes pour lancer l'ordre d'arrestation
le 13 octobre 1307.
Le jour même de l'anniversaire de...
Arrête, ça devient palpitant. Très peu
de templiers en réchappent. La plupart sont
enfermés et puisqu'il s'agit d'un ordre religieux,
Philippe le Bel ne peut pas les juger lui-même:
il fait appel à son confesseur, le Grand
Inquisiteur de France, pour mener les opérations.
Et quelles opérations puisque sous la torture,
de nombreux templiers meurent. D'autres confessent
des actes d'hérésie, d’idolâtrie d'un
dieu appelé Baphomet, de sodomie, mais on
peut comprendre qu'au vu des moyens employés
ils aient été prêts à confesser n'importe
quoi.
J'ai tué Muphasa!
Suite à ce procès qui se déroule sur plusieurs
années, le pape intervenant à plusieurs
reprises pour essayer de calmer les choses,
beaucoup de templiers sont condamnés au bûcher.
Les autres retournent à la vie civile, et
tous leurs biens sont confiés à l'ordre
des hospitaliers. Mais tout n'est pas si mal
puisque le pape Clément V absous secrètement
les dirigeants de l'ordre. Ils sont bien morts,
mais on leur a pardonné.
Peu de templiers sont arrêtés dans les autres
pays d'Europe, leurs biens sont confisqués
mais ils sont également absous.
L'ordre des templiers est définitivement
aboli en 1312, il n'a donc duré qu'environ
200 ans, mais a continué de nourrir l'imaginaire
à tel point qu'on le retrouve encore dans
de nombreuses œuvres de fiction mais aussi
dans certains ordres religieux actuels qui
se réclament des templiers.
Et je termine cette vidéo en abordant la
célèbre malédiction des templiers, prononcée
par Jacques de Molay, le dernier maître de
l'ordre, qui aurait maudit le pape, ou le
roi, ou les deux, jusqu'à la treizième génération.
La treizième génération du pape...
Il y a eu tellement de versions de cette histoire!
On en retrouve la trace pour la première
fois en 1548, soit plus de deux siècles après
les événements, et il s'agit seulement d'une
légende populaire. On peut sans trop se tromper
supposer que les derniers mots de Jacques
de Molay ont plutôt été «Oh, oh, ah,
ça brûle»
ou «Je ne sens plus mes mollets! Jacques
de Molay...»
Merci. Il y aurait beaucoup de choses à dire
sur cet ordre, la manière dont les templiers
s'habillaient, se battaient, le déroulement
de leur procès, mais j'espère que cet aperçu
vous a intéressé, et si vous voulez en savoir
plus Alain Demurger a écrit plusieurs livres
sur le sujet. Merci d'avoir regardé et à
la prochaine!
et t'oublies pas quelque chose?!